jeff bezos and his three passengers did
return safely from their brief jaunt
into space
bezos one of several billionaires we've
been talking about they spent chunks of
their own personal fortunes
on private spacecraft capable of very
short
10-minute flights all right so now what
about some of these longer trips or
permanent presence in space
george knapp has more of that
[Music]
my expectations were high and they were
dramatically
exceeded the richest man in the world
and his three fellow passengers were
pretty jazzed by their brief trip to the
edge of space
good rocket motor burn the same was true
for rival billionaire richard branson
who took his own jaunt earlier this
month
a third billionaire elon musk has plowed
his best fortune
into developing a now reliable transport
system
spacex rockets used by companies and
governments to carry satellites into
orbit
musk eventually wants to establish a
human colony on mars
bezos thinks millions of humans need to
move into space permanently
in order to save the earth all of the
space billionaires hope
space tourism can become a thriving
industry but there was another wealthy
entrepreneur who was for a time
way ahead of the others on an overlooked
essential
where are all these future space
travelers going to go
las vegas hotel chain founder robert
bigelow way back in
1999 created his own company on his own
dime
to fill a need no one else was
addressing space habitats
bigelow aerospace was built from scratch
to create
lightweight expandable space habitats
that can be carried into space at a
fraction of the cost of metallic
spacecraft
they would in essence create more space
in space
space for humans to work live take
vacations
if you look at what the international
space station would cost today
people say well it would be about 150
billion dollars
to to build that station including the
transportation of the
of the uh the modules up there to to
combine everything
and so if if we were to look at what if
we
created the same volume which is about
950 cubic meters
of habitable volume and what would it
cost us
to do that and it turns out per cubic
meter
is 148 the cost
of what the iss would cost for the same
volume
that 2019 interview took place inside a
scale model of bigelow's proposed
olympus spacecraft one of several
different models he and his team
designed over the years
bigelow spent about 350 million dollars
on his plans
paid 20 million dollars a piece for two
russian rockets
to carry his first two craft into orbit
genesis 1 in 2006
and genesis 2 in 2007. another of his
designs the beam
is at this moment attached to the iss
and has been deemed a success by nasa
during our 2019 interview 50 nasa
engineers were at the bigelow plant
to pour over every inch of a full-size
mock-up
that bigelow wanted to use as the basis
of privately owned space
stations that could serve as orbiting
labs workspaces
tourism destinations or as more
permanent habitats
on the moon or mars in his very first
on-camera interview back in 2006
bigelow told us about his hopes for more
affordable space tourism
we're hoping that we can
provide a three-week visit for somebody
in the neighborhood of eight million
dollars which is a hell of a lot of
money
but it's not as as much as 20 million
which other people
supposedly have paid the russians
bigelow optimistically hoped that by
2009 he could have as many as eight
private habitats in orbit but it never
happened each new
president scrambled nasa's priorities he
says which led to delays and impediments
to private space developments
his workforce expanded and contracted
several times
the pandemic proved the final nail
bigelow aerospace was shut down
his entire workforce was laid off and
it's unlikely he will ever reopen the
plant
private space races are risky even for
billionaires
but bigelow knows the other billionaires
in the space game
will eventually need to address the
missing piece if more people are going
to spend more time in space
they'll need a place to stay george
knapp 8 news now
if you missed any of that all over on
mysterywire.com robert bigelow told us
this afternoon he's very happy for jeff
bezos and his team
for today's successful launch and safe
return bigelow said bezos came to nevada
a few years ago to tour the bigelow
aerospace plant and he offered some
predictions on what will happen next
in the private space race you can read
his predictions
and full comments on our mysterywire.com
site